welcome back to understanding Quantum information and computation my name is John watus and I'm the technical director for education
at IBM Quantum this is the ninth lesson of the series and it's the first lesson in the third unit which is on the general
formulation of quantum information up until now we've been using the simplified formulation of
quantum information where Quantum states are represented by complex vectors having ukian Norm equal to
one in in contrast in the general formulation of quantum information Quantum states are represented by
matrices of a certain type known as density matrices this first lesson of the unit focuses on density matrices specifically
and we'll get to what they are and how they work as the lesson continues density matrices are extremely
useful and they offer various advantages that we'll discuss they allow us to represent a
broader class of States than Quantum State vectors can including States of systems that have been affected by noise for instance as well as random
selections of quantum States we'll also take a look at the Block sphere which gives us a very nice
and simple geometric way of thinking about Cubit States and we'll see how it connects with density matrices in a
pretty remarkable way through the poly matrices finally we'll discuss density matrices in the context of multiple
systems and in particular we'll see how they allow us to describe Quantum States of systems viewed in isolation even when
they're correlated with other systems and that includes the possibility that they're entangled with other systems this is an important thing to be
able to do and it's not easily done within the simplified formulation of quantum information here's an overview of the
lesson we'll start with the basics of density matrices including relevant definitions and some examples and we'll
also discuss how they connect to Quantum State vectors we'll then talk about convex combinations of density matrices or in
other words what happens when we take weighted averages of density matrices we'll start with a specific
example of the so-called completely mixed state we'll see how classical probabilistic States can be viewed as
special cases of density matrices and we'll discuss how the spectral theorem from linear algebra comes into play in
this context the third part of the lesson is on the Block sphere which provides a geometric way of viewing states of
single cubits as I mentioned at the start of the lesson and in the fourth part of the lesson we'll talk about how density matrices work for multiple
systems we'll discuss product States and correlated states of different sorts including entangled States as well as
the notion of a reduced state which is a density Matrix description of the state of an isolated part of a compound system
that can be calculated using an operation known as the partial Trace before we get to the technical content of the lesson itself it's
fitting to take just a few moments to motivate the use of density matrices using the simplified
formulation of quantum information which doesn't involve density matrices we're able to describe Quantum algorithms like
shortest factoring algorithm for instance without any difficulties so why should we bother with density matrices
or this General formulation of quantum information at all well there are multiple reasons for one density matrices
represent a broader class of quantum States than Quantum State vectors do including Quantum states where we have uncertainty or
Randomness this is important when we want to model the effects of noise on Quantum computations for
instance second using density matrices we can describe Quantum states of isolated parts of compound systems such
as the states of systems that are entangled with other systems that perhaps momentarily we choose to ignore as I mentioned at the start of
the lesson this is not easily or naturally done within the simplified formulation of quantum
information a third reason is that when we use density matrices classical information actually emerges as a
special case so instead of having what is essentially an analogy between probabilistic states and operations on
one hand and Quantum State vectors and unitary operations on the other hand we have Quantum and classical information
being described together within a single mathematical framework which is pretty much Essential to the mathematical study
of quantum information so if you're serious about understanding Quantum information at a mathematical level it's highly
recommended that you learn about density matrices let's begin with the definition of density
matrices for the sake of the definition suppose that X is a system and sigma is its classical State set and recall that
when we use that terminology our assumption is that Sigma is finite and non-empty and as always we could choose
different names if we wanted to a density Matrix describing a state of the system X is a matrix having complex
number entries whose rows and columns have been placed in correspondence with its classical State set and to be clear
it's the same correspondence for the rows and the columns simultaneously this means that density
matrices are always Square matrices and in addition to being Square there are a couple of conditions that need to be
satisfied and we'll get to them shortly people usually use certain lowercase Greek letters to name density
matrices row is often the first choice and other common choices include lowercase Sigma andai which are shown on
the screen this is just a convention but as usual these sorts of conventions are helpful because they make things more
easily recognizable and now let's talk about the conditions or the requirements that density matrices must satisfy to be
valid density matrices there are two of of them and what I'll do is to First just list them
and then I'll discuss in Greater detail what they mean the first condition is that density
matrices must have unit trace or in other words Trace equal to one and the second condition is that
density matrices must be positive semi-definite and in both cases we have concise symbolic ways of expressing
these two conditions that appear on the screen now let me discuss the two conditions in Greater detail
the first condition refers to the trace which is a very important function that's defined for all square matrices
and it's simply the sum of the diagonal entries and here's an equation that expresses that
explicitly now there's quite a lot to be said about the trace and why it's important but for now let's just observe
one very basic property of it which is that it's a linear function other properties of the trace will come up and will discuss them as
they're needed but to keep our focus on density matrices let's move on to the second requirement and that requirement is that
density matrices are positive semi-definite this is also an important concept that arises in many settings in